where did the inky boys go Bryce tell
them where we went we ain't
no well we ain't going nowhere Inky boys
Tick Tock star Bryce Gonzalez Mourns his
late father Randy who died following a
battle with colon cancer he was 35 years
old in a message attributed to Bryce on
Instagram the six-year-old tells his dad
I wish I could hug you and give you a
kiss one more time but I know you will
be watching over me Mom and the girls
until I see you again Dad I promise to
make you proud
the tribute notes his family is planning
a public Memorial and ends with the
message to fans please keep my family in
your prayers I just want to thank every
single one of you for the love and
support y'all keep on going at us Randy
chronicled his illness on social media
revealing his diagnosis last April it's
just such a blessing that and
even though this is the worst time of my
life I did not
gonna let it you know get to me the
father-son duo began making funny videos
back in 2019 those moments turned the
pair into Tick-Tock Stars
you give me some gas money you got five
dollars on you and Bryce's popularity
even got him a role on NBC's Lopez
versus Lopez my dad loves Target yeah
well
good things not your real debt yes he is
mommy says you just say that to mask
your own insecurities since your dad
left you
damn
I cut Like a Knife up top
the fact that my grandkid on the show
has 17 million Tick Tock followers is
disheartening to me as a former but
we'll catch up no I mean I mean I'm a
grandfather in this show too so yeah
um you know until mine conceives we're
gonna just do this the comedian offers
his condolences to Bryce and the entire
Gonzalez family quote the love and the
bond Randy had for his son and his
family was undeniable he will be missed
but never forgotten
[Music]
foreign